Oh, in myth,
she was called the Redeemer.
do you know the story of the Princess Isa
It was said this child would stop
the madness of World War
Two due to
I was given memories of a world
I will never see.
What loyalty to a king I cannot serve
that, she was to usher in a new age
of peace and compassion.
More and more,
and love for a child
I could not see.
I found her
skull, her
What do you think they want?
Everything.
name, Child of war.
I was taught that love is weakness.
One moment.
I do love this part.
There is a difference
between justice and revenge.
Here is the price to pay
for your defiance.
Hold on.
I don't want no trouble.
We're not here to bring any.
And so we're not afraid.
So then we are more than the shackles
that bind us.
Are you ready?
You and I both know fear.
The time has come for all the to love
The king is a man, and a man can fail.
But a myth
is indestructible.
and protect each other.
The numerous.
Who among you is willing to die
for what you believe?
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Zack Snyder just dropped a brand new Rebel
Moon trailer for the Netflix movie.
That's coming up later this year. It's
actually part one of part two.
I'll explain what's going on
with the two different parts,
Because one of the reasons
why they release
the trailer at Gamescom
is because they're releasing a game
based on the events of the two movies
that'll be set after the events of those.
So I'll explain that to.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course I'll do. More trailer videos
as they release them.
But we're also getting Asoka episodes
tonight.
I'll be doing videos for that as well.
So be sure to enable alerts
for my channels
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
funny coincidence because a lot of this
movie was inspired by Zack Snyder's
original Star Wars movie
that he had developed for Lucasfilm
before he started
the Snyder verse of DC movies.
Back when the Man of Steel movie,
when he was on stage announcing
the trailer, he talked a little bit
about other influences, too, like that
classic Heavy metal magazine.
He liked the vibe of that.
Everybody remembers
The heavy metal movie is a classic
just in general,
the whole vibe, the tone, just the look.
The feel of the movie is inspired by seven
Samurai Kurosawa films, which Star Wars
films as well.
But Star Wars itself, George Lucas said,
was inspired by classic Kurosawa films.
a lot of you have commented
that you're seeing a lot of Battle
Beyond the Stars influences in here, too.
the whole idea is that you have this evil
empire, like the empire in Star Wars.
There's an empire,
so to speak, played by Carrie, always.
What it looks
like is going on in the trailer
is that Sophia Battle is core character
who sort of the protagonist
puts together this ragtag group of people
who all used to be members
of the empire's military,
either generals or soldiers
or just various people
throughout their military
and for whatever reason, they all left.
At some point, something tragic,
something terrible happened, or the empire
made them do something terrible.
usually involves
killing a bunch of innocent people,
pretty much the same vibe that you get
from the Empire in Star Wars
during the original trilogy.
So no coincidence that we're actually
seeing the resurrection of the Empire
with Thrawn in the Ahsoka series episodes
starting tonight.
Pretty soon, Zack Snyder didn't
intend to time things that way on purpose.
Just a big coincidence.
The first movie is coming out later
this year.
That's what this trailer footage is for.
Part one is called Child of a Fire,
which is probably a reference
to chorus childhood
in the circumstances of her rise.
I don't know.
This is necessarily
meant to be from her backstory,
but this could be a reference to that.
something
similar could have happened to her.
Like she came from a world
that the Empire destroyed
and she just became
a member of their military
there a lot of sci fi,
a lot of fantasy storylines
that are similar to this
where like the character
finds out what really happened,
what their origin really was
and how the empire wronged them.
And eventually she rebels against them.
Zack Snyder also made a lot of dirty dozen
references,
just a ragtag group of people
that she winds up putting together.
Some of them used to be members
of the Empire's military, some of them not
Rebel Moon.
Part two is coming out
next year is called the Scar Giver.
Also probably a reference to Kora,
maybe a name
she was given
when she was a soldier of the Empire.
In scenes like this.
It stars Charlie Hunnam, Djimon Hounsou,
Anthony Hopkins of the battle,
a whole bunch of familiar faces
that you see like screen.
Velt was a settlement
known mostly for farming.
It's where the heroes of Rebel Moon
started their journey
When the Imperium arrived for their food,
Ray Fisher is playing Darian Bloodaxe
alongside his sister Deborah.
They're low resource resistance fighters.
Charlie Hunnam is playing Kai.
He's a mercenary Djimon
Hounsou is general.
Titus was an Imperium general
or former general who turned on the world
he once defended to live a sad life
fighting in a coliseum
his experience
being a general in their forces
scarred him, causing him to leave
and become a gladiator.
he was a former ally of Kora.
So when she's looking to defend Belt
from the Imperium, he's
the first person that she goes to.
Michelle Huisman is playing gunner.
He's another farmer living on built.
That becomes part of their resistance.
Carrie Elway's, of all people, is playing
the King of the Galactic Empire.
Like the King of the Imperium, from Free
is playing the Regent
Bala sorry is he's
the leader of the Imperium invasion
In screen is playing the Admiral Noble,
who's another leader in their forces.
these really crazy
looking people behind them.
And these awesome costumes
are called scribes.
They're part of a religious group
on the Imperium Homeworld, tasked
with writing down
the history of the galaxy.
within the universe, a rebel moon
they call the Imperium Homeworld
Mother World.
But a lot of the history
that the scribes write down is influenced
by the politics of the Imperium.
So they aren't always necessarily writing
down the true history of the galaxy.
The shirtless dude here with the crazy
abs is Tarik.
He was a member of a noble family
in the Imperium,
but after his family had a run with Mother
World, Terek wound up owing a life debt
to a rancher for whom
he worked as an indentured servant
honor bound to see out his debt.
So when Cora is going around
trying to recruit resistance
fighters, he initially refuses,
but eventually agrees to join them.
The movie's about a peaceful colony
on the edge of the galaxy
that's threatened by the armies
of a tyrannical regent named Belisarius.
The desperate civilians dispatch
a young woman who has a mysterious past
to seek out warriors from nearby planets
to help them challenge the region
Anthony Hopkins is playing Jimmy.
He's a robot knight, this character here.
And Sophia Boutella
is playing the titular Kora, who's
going around trying to defend the planet.
I don't think her name. Kora
was inspired by Kora
from the Legend of Korra in the Avatar
universe.
Netflix also just released
a teaser trailer for their live action
Avatar, The Last Airbender.
I did a video for It's
all link at the end of this.
The large ship landing seems like
it belongs to the evil Regent character.
this is actually Zack Snyder talking
about the film with Michael Giacchino,
who just got done
directing Werewolf By Night for Marvel.
there is a community on a planet,
a farming planet, and
these there's a bunch of bad guys.
The mother
World's armies are in the area
and they need to be fed.
So they they come to the village
and ask for the village
to feed them basically,
while they're doing their war.
And that area of the galaxy.
And of course,
they are not
kind about asking.
And the result would probably be
the obliteration of the village
and so the villagers decide to fight.
And so, you know,
they have to go out into the galaxy
and collect
some soldiers to warriors to help them.
because the movie is two parts
and part two is coming out next year.
I'm assuming
there'll be some kind of cliffhanger
ending like some WTF moment
that they leave
things on that pushes into the beginning
of the second film, into explain
that video game that Zack Snyder explained
is going to be based on the two movies.
He said It'll take place
after the events of the movies
and you'll play like a Rebel
that you can pick and you go on missions.
but generally is meant to expand
the universe of Rebel Moon like he plans
to turn this into a much bigger
Star Wars universe of his own at Netflix
that he can just play in.
So he probably has plans for sequels,
for prequels, for spinoff movies.
You get the idea
He already kind of did that with his Army
of the Dead franchise of movies,
like he released another movie
within that universe
that was meant to spin off
from the last one that he just released.
generally the trailer looks really crazy,
so everybody just posts
all your reactions in the comments below.
Like there's a whole bunch of new IP
that he's trying to introduce
you like a whole bunch of worldbuilding,
that is.
But you can see the influences
of what used to be a Star Wars movie,
like a bunch of space Nazis
with a giant empire, an empire
that they're all trying to stand against.
a bunch of rebels, standing
against an empire Big reminder to my Ahsoka
episode one video we'll post later tonight
after they air the episode,
but they're airing episode
two back to back My Episode two video
won't post till Wednesday morning.
After that, episodes will be one per week.
They're eight episodes total,
just like The Mandalorian.
It's meant to be connected
to The Mandalorian.
It'll take place
right after the Mandalorian season 3.
Click here for that Ahsoka Episode
one Video.
Update the link as soon as I post
that and click here for that Henry Cavill
Warhammer trailer for his new series.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!